hello folks how are you
welcome
welcome
wish you're here in person one of these
days we're going to be able to do that
again
i want to thank you for joining us and
uh
happy new year and before we begin i
want to say a word
about where our economy stands today
we're entering
position of a unique economic strength
six million new jobs a record number for
a new president been created since
january last
unemployment is down to 4.2 percent
three years ahead of predictions
new small business applications are up
over 30 percent
compared with before the pandemic
and the fastest growth of an america in
nearly 40 years
and america is the only leading economy
in the world
where the economy as a whole is stronger
than it was before the pandemic
even after accounting for price
increases
because uh because we took action for
the american rescue plan and a
bipartisan infrastructure law we made
important progress we've begun to change
the trajectory change the trajectory of
our economy the one that we had
inherited
to finally make it work for working
people
to build up from the bottom up in the
middle out and to give working people
the wages and benefits they deserve
and to encourage more innovation and
faster growth so now
we're in a strong position to address
the challenge we face and we have
challenges including the cost and prices
that people have to pay
we already laid out three
a three-part plan to address costs that
families are facing number one
fix the supply chains we're gonna have
another discussion on that in a couple
weeks with the secretary of agriculture
protecting consumers number two
three lowering kitchen table costs
including with my buildback better plan
but today
we're here to talk about strengthening
competition
which will bring down cost
back in july
i signed an executive order to promote
competition across the economy
in too many industries
a handful of giant companies dominate
the market
and too often they use their power to
squeeze out smaller competitors and
stifle new entrepreneurs making our
economy less dynamic giving themselves
free reign to raise prices reduce
options for consumers or exploit workers
the meat industry is a textbook example
on the price side
four big corporations control more than
half the markets in beef
pork and poultry
these middle men
that they buy from
farmers and ranchers
and sell the processors they assume you
sell the process
excuse me sell the processed product to
grocery stores that's the that's the way
it works
without meaningful competition farmers
and ranchers don't get to choose who
they sell to
or put another way
our farmers and ranchers have to pay
whatever these
four big companies say they have to pay
by and large
but that's only half of it
these companies can use their position
as middlemen to overcharge grocery
stores and ultimately families
if we can hold a second i was just i was
telling the
my colleagues earlier in my office that
i was sitting in my kitchen yesterday
and there's a sunroom off the kitchen
and my wife was there with her sister
and a good friend named marianne
and she was saying do you realize it's
over five dollars for a pound of
hamburger meat
five dollars
well this is partly you know the pound
of beef today costs five bucks compared
to less than four bucks before the
pandemic
and here's some historical context
50 years ago ranchers got over 60 cents
for every dollar a family spent on beef
today
they get about 39 cents
50 years ago hog farmers got 40 to 50
cents for each dollar they spent
today it's about 19 cents
and the big companies are making massive
profits
while their profits go up the prices you
see the grocery stores go up
commensurate
the prices farmers receive for the
products they are bringing to market go
down
this reflects the market being distorted
by lack of competition
i've said it before and i'll say it
again
capitalism without competition isn't
capitalism it's exploitation
that's what we're seeing in meat and
poultry in those industries now
small independent farmers and ranchers
are being driven out of business
sometimes businesses that have been
around for generations
it strikes that their dignity their
respect and the family legacy so many of
them carried for generations after
generation
so i'm here as secretary of agriculture
tom vilsack former governor of the state
of iowa and attorney general garf
garland to talk about how we can create
fair markets and more opportunities for
family farmers and ranchers and bring
down the price at grocery stores
there are four pieces of our action plan
first
we're going to invest 1 billion dollars
in new and expanded meat and poultry
processing capacity
funding
that was
included in the american rescue plan to
revive our economy
to bring down to bring in more
competition and dignity and more farmers
ranchers and customers we're going to
invest in new and innovative small
businesses and meat processors the
lifeblood of our economy
and when we do this
we'll give farmers and ranchers more
options beyond giant processing
conglomerates shore up the weak points
on our food supply chain
secretary vilsack will share some about
this very shortly
second
we're strengthening rules to protect
farmers ranchers and other producers
for example
the department of agriculture
is rewriting the rules under the packers
and stockyard act which was the law back
in the 20s
that was needed at that time and still
needed to protect farmers and ranchers
from abuse by processors
the last administration weakened that
law making it possible for the abuse
that we're seeing now
we're going to strengthen the law to
make sure it works as intended
third
the united states government
my administration will enforce existing
competition laws vigorously and fairly
my executive order on competition
established the whole government
approach to increasing competition
and our new white house competition
council chaired by the head of my
national economic council including
members and brian is here today
including members of the cabinet and
other key agency officials like the
secretary of agriculture the attorney
general the secretary of labor the head
of the federal trade commission they're
all there to make sure that antitrust
laws are enforced across the board
today the justice department and the
usda
announced a joint initiative to make it
easier for farmers and ranchers to
report potentially illegal practices in
the agricultural sector
attorney general garland will discuss
this more
fourth
we're bringing greater transparency to
the industry
a free market isn't truly free without
transparency around prices
how do you justify the price
and right now that's largely disappeared
in the cattle market transparency
back in august
the department of agriculture took steps
to address this
and we're going to keep pushing
and i'm pleased to see that congress is
taking action as well to increase
competition and fairness with a
bipartisan group of senators now working
on legislation to make cattle markets
more transparent
and all these issues
all these issues are areas where we can
and we must come together in a
bipartisan way
and i'm grateful to the members of the
democratic and republican administration
of
members of congress for being willing to
come to the table
senator john tester and senator grassley
of iowa testers from montana have been
leaders in this effort
and i'll be inviting a bipartisan group
to come together to discuss how we can
make progress legislatively as well as
they're proposing
even as we continue doing everything we
can on the executive branch side
strengthening competition is good for
all of us
farmers and ranchers deserve a fair
shake
american families facing high prices at
grocery stores deserve a fair price to
put food on the table
rural communities which seem more good
jobs when there's more competition
and our economy as a whole as we make
our food supply chains more resilient
i'm looking forward to hearing from the
farmers ranchers and processors joining
us today
we're going to ensure that you have the
tools you need
on a level playing field you deserve
and we're going to fight for fair prices
for american farmers ranchers and
families all three
with that i'm going to turn it over to
secretary vilsack
tom the floor is yours mr president
thank you very much and uh certainly as
i've traveled around the country i've
heard
uh sad stories of farmers and farm
families who've had to leave this
business because of a lack of
competition your executive order on
competition challenged us at usda to
take immediate action and to develop a
set of tools to expand processing
capacity increase competition improve
farm income and create good paying jobs
in rural america
and we went to work and because of your
american rescue plan we have the
resources to be able to do meaningful
work committing over one billion dollars
broken down as follows a hundred million
dollars is going to be utilized to
reduce the cost of inspections for
existing small and very small processing
facilities this is going to help us
maintain the capacity we have
32 million dollars in grants were
awarded 267
existing facilities to modernize their
operations to allow them to expand their
opportunities beyond the state border uh
to engage in interstate commerce this is
going to expand market opportunity and
income opportunities for these
processors a hundred million dollars in
available loan guarantees to address the
middle level supply chain challenges
that this industry faces
cold storage warehousing and also
allowing these facilities to expand
their operations as well we believe this
hundred million dollars will leverage
nearly a billion dollars of investment
and the announcement today we make is an
800 million dollar commitment of grants
and loans to address capacity workforce
and innovation challenges the industry
faces
we're going to make available mr
president 375 million dollars in grants
for expanded facilities and new
construction of new facilities now we
want to get to work right away because
farmers have been waiting a long time
for this help so 150 million dollars of
of this resource is going to be made
available under a request for proposal
that will file this spring
these resources will be made available
to projects that are just about ready to
get going but just need a little bit of
help to accelerate uh the implementation
plan so this 150 million dollars we
believe will help to sponsor at least 15
new projects that will complement expand
along the 50 facilities that that you
mentioned earlier that the major four
companies currently have so it's a
significant step forward
225 million dollars of grants will then
be made available this summer for
products and for projects that are just
getting started that are on the on in
the infant infant stage
our phase one goal as i indicated is 15
projects
additional 275 million dollars mr
president it's going to be provided to
our lending partners
to create more affordable uh loans and
financing available for
facilities that are that are that are
being built
even if we build more facilities we also
need a trade workforce
mr president so 100 million dollars of
this resource is going to be used to
support and to create a pipeline of
well-trained and experienced workers so
that we can expand this workforce in
rural america these will be good paying
jobs
that will support families and also
support farm families mr president and
then 50 million dollars of it is going
to be utilized for technical assistance
and research we're going to need a lot
of innovation in this industry
we're going to need
new business models we're going to need
new ways of innovation and technology to
create greater efficiencies and small
and mid-sized facilities need to have
the opportunity to have this innovation
as opposed uh to the big four
now as you indicated it's not just about
money it's also about rules and
regulations and we are strengthening uh
our packers and stockyards enforcement
effort uh by leveling the playing field
for producers and processors uh and
we're also working on a a voluntary
label program called product of the usa
to allow consumers to know exactly where
their resources their consuming dollar
is being spent uh we think this is going
to better inform consumers in making
choices and we're looking forward to the
creative partnership that we have with
the department of justice a strong
working relationship in terms of
enforcement mr president what this
really is all about at the end of the
day is improving farm income
it's about creating good paying jobs in
rural america that are so necessary
it's about giving the consumers choice
and a break at the grocery store
and it's exciting work and we at usda
are really engaged in this and involved
in working with our farm partners as a
suspect you'll hear today
there are stories of woe out there but
we are committed to making a difference
and we're looking forward to working
with
attorney general garland and his great
team at department of justice in terms
of antitrust enforcement so i'll turn it
over
to my friend the attorney general
thank you very much mr president for
convening this very important meeting
and thank you
mr secretary for the tremendous
engagement our teams have had over the
past year on our shared
uh
competition and regulatory concerns
the justice department takes very
seriously our responsibility to share
with our partners across the federal
government to protect consumers
safeguard competition
ensure economic opportunity and fairness
for all
over the past 10 months we've stepped up
our efforts to ensure competition and
counter anti-competitive practices
across all sectors from airlines to
insurance brokers to book publishers
and we will continue to vigorously
enforce our antitrust law laws no matter
the industry
no matter the company and no matter the
individual
the work that we do especially the work
that we do together to ensure
competition in our economy has a direct
impact on the lives of the american
people every single day
when we talk about promoting competition
in the agricultural sector we are
talking about whether a farmer or a
rancher will be paid a fair and
competitive price
for their goods and labor
when we talk about protecting consumers
in this context we are talking about
whether food will be affordable for
everyone in america
the justice department's antitrust
division has been active in implementing
the sound policy
measures suggested in the president's
executive order on promoting competition
in the american economy
we have closely supported usda's
rulemaking efforts under the packers and
stockyards act a law that congress
passed a hundred years ago more than a
hundred years ago to deal with many of
the very same problems we still have
today
today we are announcing a new joint
initiative to better coordinate efforts
between usda and doj
this will include the launch of a
centralized accessible portal
one-stop shop to report complaints of
potential violations
of our competition laws including the
sherman and the clayton act as well as
the packers and stockyards act
the joint channel that we are
establishing will allow usda and doj to
collaborate early on
on how to appropriately address such
complaints
where complaints relate to antitrust
violations whistleblowers will be
protected in many cases by the new
employee and contractor anti-retaliation
protections which congress passed in
2020
let me say in closing that
anti-competitive practices in
agriculture as in any industry hurt the
american people
producers consumers and workers alike
and they hurt the american economy
too many industries have become too
consolidated over time
too many companies have pursued
corporate conduct and more aggressive
mergers that have made all of us
vulnerable
against this background our antitrust
efforts cannot and will not slow down
but it is a fact that our anti-trust
division has been underfunded for too
long and has fewer staff today than it
had in the 1970s
that is why we are urging congress to
allocate the resources we need to
reinvigorate our enforcement efforts
and ensure a competitive economy for all
americans
i look forward to our work together in
the days ahead
thank you very much
thank you mr attorney general and uh mr
president uh if you may we're gonna uh
hear from a uh the uh group that we have
assembled here which represents the
enormous uh potential and uh diversity
uh geographic and otherwise in this uh
in this industry um and we're going to
start here with uh scott uh scott puba
who is the president of the oklahoma
farm farmers union uh and operates a uh
cattle rat ranch in oklahoma and i just
uh scott opened it to you
and would be curious to hear how you
approach the issue of
the options for processing
and what what it would mean to you to
have more options and how you think
about that in the context of the action
steps that we're trying to put forward
today
well thank you uh
thank you mr president for taking on
this
very critical issue for uh rural america
um
you know
this is on our minds of all of our
farmers and ranchers throughout the
country
and not not since teddy roosevelt had we
have a president that's willing to take
on
this big issue so thank you very much
for that
as uh to answer your question what will
it do for me as a farmer and rancher and
my membership
here in oklahoma and and the american
farmers and ranchers
is if we are able to uh be able to
process our animals
uh on a more local level
we can retain more of that retail food
dollar
in our at our farm gates and our farms
and ranches in our family operations
and in our rural communities uh for too
long we have seen multinational
meat packers suck out all of the wealth
of rural america and put it in their
corporate coffers and in some cases even
overseas
so we're excited about being able to
have
local processing done by local people
and then sell directly to the consumer
um
you know whether we can sell to the
grocery stores the restaurants
or the consumers directly
all of these will will enable our rural
communities to be lifted out of poverty
and we have a great
poverty problem in rural america
so we're excited about that in oklahoma
i will tell you uh 10 million dollars of
the first round
of of the cares covet money was actually
allocated through our oklahoma
department of agriculture
to fund some
projects just as you're speaking of
so we had 196 applicants apply for
that 10 million dollars of care's money
40 applicants were
chosen
uh and were able to be funded with that
money and out of that we had 19 new
mom and pr pop small processors either
open up for business here in our state
or they were able to upgrade an old
facility to meet the new safety and
health standards
and be able to market that across state
lines
we also
have had great success working with our
tribal neighbors
here in uh in oklahoma's many of our
tribal organizations their governments
have
uh put new processing online or are in
the process of it
processing both their cattle and their
buffalo
and their excess capacity that these new
clients has created
has also given our independent farmers
and ranchers in the community
an opportunity to get their cattle
processed and marketed so we're very
very pleased with that
and look forward to everything i heard
here today
what scott said at the beginning was
that this was a critical issue for rural
america
and i think it's critical uh from two
perspectives that he raised one
the notion of keeping the dollars in the
rural communities where the dollars are
being and the wealth is being generated
for far too long we've had an extraction
economy in rural america where these
guys work 24 7 365 days a year raising
these cattle and then they transport
them hundreds of miles away and the
profits basically go thousands of miles
away
what scott's talking about is retaining
those profits in the small towns that's
going to create opportunities for
farmers to be able to more better afford
that machinery that's going to keep the
implement dealer in business they're
going to be able to
support that main street business that's
going to keep those retail stores
in business
and it also going to create jobs and i
think it's really important to emphasize
it's not just farmers who are going to
benefit from this it's also rural folks
looking for a decent job
and if we do this right with workforce
training uh with assistance we can have
good paying jobs to complement what's
happening on the farm so
this is this is an incredible thing just
so you understand how how diff dire this
is mr president and i'll finish with
this
i was in council bluffs iowa talking to
a farmer uh this summer
and he came up to me and he said uh mr
secretary thank you so much for doing
this he said i just sold a load of
cattle
and he said this is what irritates me
about this whole system
i lost a hundred and fifty dollars ahead
150 ahead i lost on this on this cattle
but i know the processor that purchased
those cattle is going to make eighteen
hundred dollars ahead
and he looked at me and he said
mr secretary how is that fair
it's not
asking a question
scott
um when you talk about um
you said uh
um
be able to
go locally
how far
do you have to go before
these smaller operations opened up
to sell your cattle i mean the average
farmer cattlemen in iowa or in
oklahoma or you know wherever
how far do they have to take their
cattle to actually sell them
well if we sell to the if we sell the
cattle to the big four
uh processors then um you know it's
several hundred miles
uh and and it's a little bit misleading
that we have four
of these very large companies the
processors but they're looking located
uh more regionally so in many cases
there's only one option
to sell to
and so it's a take it or leave it price
that you're offered
so when we try to
go around that system
and
and not give our cattle away to these
companies but if we can process them on
a local level
and then sell directly to consumers it's
just a win-win for everybody it's a win
for the consumer they get more choices
uh in my opinion they get a better
product
and we know because of the pandemic has
shown us and proven to us
that consumers want to buy local if they
can
and they want to know where their food
comes from
and uh and they trust the american
farmer and rancher
uh
to do that and
their faith in the american farmer
interest far greater than any of these
multinational companies so
it's just a win-win for everyone i see
except maybe the these four companies
we're talking about
thank you
so um mr president i want to ask corwin
heatwell uh to come in uh corwin is the
founding farmer and ceo of farm focus
and and to to to pick up on the last
point uh corbin's on the front line of
actually innovating and creating an
alternative processing uh facility uh in
the poultry industry so cory can you
talk a little bit about what motivated
you to do it and the challenges that
you've had in building your company
yes thank you and
as a sixth generational farmer i greatly
value the farming lifestyle
but it was grieving when i saw dozens of
farms closing down
around me and i realized that my own
farm was not viable for the next
generation
and we knew that something had to be
done
but there was no option for us to get
our animals uh processed locally and
everyone kept telling us that farmers
don't start chicken companies
so with no other options
we started a company with a mission to
promote and protect generational family
farms
and we're now partnered with 73
independent family farmers and on track
to exceed 100 this year
we're also providing poultry products
for around 1 million
consumers and
our unique and scalable model of
partnering with farmers focuses on the
financial viability and sustainability
and it brings solutions to the three
pain points that exist with the
conglomerates
one the lack of
ownership of animals in inventory on the
farm second the lack of operational
control that belongs in the hands of the
farmers and third is
the tournament pay system that plays
farmers against each other
and we found that when you empower
farmers with ownership and control
enabling farms to be
viable and sustainable for the next
generation that incredible success
stories emerge of farmers returning to
success from the brink of bankruptcy
and you even see the next generation
returning to the farm
and we've seen the average age of our
farmers now trend about 10 years
below the national average
this model
has enabled a resilient community of
thriving
farmers while bringing the consumers the
transparent and traceable products that
they've been looking for and we're
excited that this administration is
focused on increasing the capabilities
that create more options for
generational family farmers
and we ourselves
look forward to partnering on these new
programs to expand and touch more
farmers and communities
we believe that together we will
continue to level the playing field for
farmers and ranchers
while establishing a more resilient
supply network so we we thank you for
your diligence in helping preserve
the legacy of the american farmer
well thank you thank you you know
everybody i come from the state of
delaware
everybody thinks the big industry is
chemicals it's chickens
chickens broiler chickens
billion dollar industries
and uh needs help
so anyway sorry i'm gonna get too
personal here
um uh so we're gonna move to the next uh
set but we're gonna um uh pause for a
moment and uh for the press to exit okay
[Music]
are you gonna break up the big four meat
packers
thanks for your patience
um
you